when it comes to bigger decisions
like directing the family and the future
of the family i can wholeheartedly
think that men should have that final
decision
so that in my house i'll tell you it
doesn't work like that and how it works
is we both come to the table on big
decisions now there are certain things
that i don't care as much about as he
does there's certain things that he
doesn't care that much about but i do
for example if we're going to go on a
vacation i'd be picky about the hotel
but probably not as picky about the
location so it's a give and take but
every big decision that affects the
family unit we sit down and we really
talk it through until we're both
comfortable with that decision and
that's how it goes down it's not a my
way or the highway type of situation in
my house i would never want that and i
think
i think there's going to be a lot of
women that don't feel comfortable with
that dynamic yeah well i think that a
lot of women get stuck up on the uh
i think that if you're a woman and
you're married to a man you should
respect his ability to make decisions
and you should trust that he has he's
going to make those decisions with your
best interest and i always like to say i
think that
i think that for efficiency purposes
one leader is the best way to go when i
was on the rugby team i was a wing so
like i'm the guy that scores all the
tries and even though i score all the
tries the captain of the team is the
captain because he has the most
experience now i could be there and i
could go hey uh captain we i see this
guy he's a little bit weaker i think i
can run around him i think i can score
maybe we should dish the ball out to me
him being the captain and having more
experience he can say no i know that guy
played against him he's just baiting you
he's actually really good or he can say
you're right you let's make that
decision so i believe that women are the
neck and men of the head so women can
have a say in what direction we go but
you should trust the man to make the
final decision because you trust his
decision-making skills because of the
results that he's shown what if he
doesn't have on that particular issue
the experience though what if it's about
something where she's
lived in a bunch of places or she grew
up in a family where x y and z happen
that gives a lens that's really
important where she may be better fit to
make that particular decision to you
yeah i think this should happen yeah but
i think that she can um
propose the decision and the man can say
based on what he knows if that's a good
decision or not and he should also trust
if you got a good leader he's also going
to trust you too so like the captain of
the team he knows that i score he knows
my capability he knows that how much i
know about the game so if he thinks that
i'm making the right decision he's going
to say yeah let's do that especially if
he knows that he doesn't
he hasn't been say if he wasn't paying
attention to what's been going on or
whatever it may be he might say yeah go
ahead and do it let's do that because
that's the best i think that that would
be a good decision based on what you've
presented to me but i think that when it
comes to the final decision in any kind
of big situation men should make it
because men tend to think more on logic
instead of emotion so that would be the
one area i think where you and i
disagree a little bit um i do think that
women factor in emotion more that we're
both
in agreement on but i i'm a firm
believer in a partnership so oh oh no i
like uh i like traditional marriage i
like you have been wife
well i want husband and wife too
traditionally you know babies and uh
yeah
yeah so for me
and i think i think that there are a lot
of women who and it's interesting
because um
it doesn't rub me wrong that you say
that because i'm i'm also a firm
believer that everyone should build the
family structure that's comfortable for
them you know if that works for you and
your house and great you know and if it
doesn't work in my house that's okay too
but there is a large segment of the
female population that will hear that
wrong that they'll want to say
well i want to say you know a marriage
is supposed to be a partnership and if
we're making a big decision for example
as to where them where to move the
family
i want to be with someone who wants me
to have a say so that's one area where
we'll disagree where i feel like that
mutual respect in a relationship for me
comes from an acknowledgement on both
sides
that each person's voice matters in
those big decisions so like
okay so say like you so you know pbd
right yeah right so you work under pbd
if you went up to pvd and said you had
an idea for something and he said he
didn't want to do it because i think it
was a good idea or if he said he did
want to do it you trust him to be able
to make that decision don't you well
he's my well he's not technically my
boss actually he's my partner but that's
a different dynamic so i would always
stray from comparing a marriage to a
business business arrangement really
that's something in business where
it really depends i mean he's been doing
this for longer than i have and i would
in that instance say you know what i'm
going to give his ability i do trust him
or i wouldn't be here doing this
partnership with him but
a marriage is not a business why do you
think why do you trust the decision that
do you trust the decision that he's
going to make because you think that he
knows more about it like he he i think
that
i think that i
would be inclined probably to trust the
decision for now yeah and feel it out
and see and if i still feel strongly and
differently in a few months go back to
that table and say this needs to change
here's why let's give it let's give it a
go and we've had actually some of those
discussions and had things changed you
know oh let her try this out let's see
how it goes you know so but i don't ever
compare a marriage to a business but go
ahead but i'm just saying like so then
if you if we both agree that men make
tend to make decisions logically but in
the same men though i said you asked me
about pbd no i'm just saying earlier
before we uh we agreed that men tend to
think of things logically while women
tend to think of things more emotionally
when it comes to life decisions which
person do you think is going to be more
likely to make the better decision i
would agree that the logic because of
the sense of the ability to rational
more or to use rationale more is gonna
have better results in the long run
that's why i think for at for most
people that's the best way to do it i
don't think i mean maybe for not
everybody i don't know how people want
to do their thing yeah yeah but um i
think it depends i think it gets very
dangerous when we start to say
that
you should just wing it and just do what
you feel because a lot of girls are
gonna feel like they can make that
decision because like i said when you're
younger you're told that you're right by
everybody but that doesn't mean that
you're actually making the better
decisions and
if you trust your man to be the leader
because he's shown results and i don't
think that you should marry a man unless
he's shown that he can be a leader and
has shown results i don't care what he's
talking about and i believe the same
thing for my daughter if you trust that
man to make the decisions because you
selected him as a husband you should let
him make the final decision that i don't
mean you can't propose something that
don't mean you can't even have a 45-55
but when it comes to the final decision
if the man is more likely to make it off
rationale and experience then i think
that he should be the one that gets the
final decision if you like the short
clip you can catch another one here or
you can catch the full episode right
here
[Music]